you guys seem like you still have so
much fun together we do we have a blast
we really do
what's the secret
just keep it light
happy juice keep it light just lots of
juice enjoy the moment uh you know we're
like like we said earlier we've been
blessed and fortunate to have a blast to
be able to do this for
25 years plus
you know it's been it's been a lot of
fun and i think we're we're kind of
taking in
you know all of the the the drippings
that we've been able to uh the drippings
i'd rather not take in your drippings
but it's all the same to you
i'm bound to screw it up yeah no but
like drew i think we have an
appreciation for
what we're able to do and and i think
we're having more fun than we ever have
i think we have more fun singing
together than we ever have more fun
being with each other than we ever have
so i guess it's just perspective as you
you know you get a little older you have
a better perspective on on the
opportunity and the blessings and
the kind of and the drippings
and that's what that's what we're it's
what we're living right now we going for
trappings
i don't know
uh well i do have to talk about this
blind and the ultimatum we're all
obsessed are you guys obsessed with
reality shows as well they can't stop
talking to me about it are you serious i
have a strict rule that if nick is doing
something i do not watch it
i'm kidding i'm kidding
no
no i think i think it's funny because
not not funny i think it's awesome the
show but i think you know to to see him
up there and like
managing this this
acting like i know anything about
relationships
it's funny for people that know
him and v it's it's um
it's it's he does a great job i mean
this guy carries three or four
unscripted shows
yeah
and you know what it does it it injects
uh some life into our careers as well
you know what i mean it keeps uh keeps
people looking at 98 degrees as well he
handles it's what handles it well this
stuff started to develop when we were
kind of you know taking our break and so
for nick to go out there and kind of
reinvent himself and do this stuff for
us he's been fantastic i appreciate it
thank you i like your answer much better
than jesus
save it in some way i mean obviously
he's nick i mean he's nick lachey not
just nick nick lachey
the king and queen um reality tv show
right now like especially dating shows
well i mean with you i guess three years
ago four years ago whenever we did the
first season of love is blind you do
something that's new like that and fresh
you have no idea if it's gonna work or
it's gonna resonate with people and so
it's been a lot of fun to see how how
well it's done and how much people have
responded to it and you know from that
opportunity then with the same
production company we'd be able to do
the ultimatum which also did very well
for netflix and um and so yeah it's very
cool to you know when you have a good
relationship it's it's fun to kind of
continue to
you know to to uh
to have fun with that relationship and
we have a great one with netflix and
with with kinetic so um yeah we and it's
honestly it's an opportunity for us to
work together which is you know which is
nice and and uh and so
it's not for everybody but we enjoy
working together and and so yeah we're
uh we're very blessed i mean that's all
you really say how much fun do you have
watching back the episodes because you
don't see what happens in the pods when
it comes to love is flying how much fun
do you and vanessa have watching these
episodes yeah i mean we in the first
season we had a little more we were
around a little bit more we saw a little
bit more what was happening so now we we
truly show up and we we kind of have to
get the the cliff note update like who
dealt with who how did it you know work
so we're just as engaged as anyone else
when we you know we watch it um
it's uh look it's a fascinating kind of
social experiment and i think that's why
people have responded to it and um and
again we're as even as the hosts we're
as intuitive and as curious and as
engaged as as anyone else watching so
um yeah season three coming soon hey
okay if y'all were single
who do you think would do the best on a
dating reality show
oh it wouldn't be me no why i don't
think any of them
but i don't think so i just um i mean
it's a whole new genre that sort of
developed after our time so i don't know
if i'd be i'd be great of it i think
justin i feel like justin justin would
be the rock star in that sort of well if
that's what you think then i think
you're probably right
trust your judgment nick do you think
you do well in it
i you know i kind of ask myself that
question because when you post something
like that you kind of put yourself in
the and i don't know it's it's it's uh
you know i think the best thing you
could do and that's what i tell them at
the start of every season is be yourself
you know i mean like the worst thing you
do is just be a poser and try and be
something you're not if it works out
great at least you know you were you
know you were true to yourself and if it
doesn't you can walk away you know
feeling good about it but um yeah you
got to be authentic i think if you're
not it it reads through it doesn't you
know it's never going to work out well
for you so as long as you're authentic
and you're truly who you are i think
you'll be fine listen interviewing you
guys interviewing 98 degrees in turks
and caicos teenage me is dying
so excited to talk to you guys you're
everything i wanted you to be you're so
nice you guys are so talented so thanks
so much thank you thank you thank you
thanks for taking the time